we're now going to explore factoring a
type of expression called a difference
of squares and the reason why it's
called a difference of squares is
because it's expressions like
x squared minus 9. this is a difference
we're subtracting between two quantities
that are each squares this is literally
x
squared let me do a different color
this is
x
squared
minus
3
squared it's the difference between two
quantities that have been squared it
turns out that this is pretty
straightforward to factor
and to see
how it can be factored let me pause
there for a second and get a little bit
of review of multiplying binomials so
put this on the back burner a little bit
before i give you the answer of how you
factor this
let's do a little bit of an exercise
let's multiply
x plus a
times x minus a where a is some number
and we can use that do that using either
the foil method but i like just thinking
of this as a distributive property twice
we could take x plus a
and distribute it onto the x and onto
the a
so when we multiply it by x
we would get x times x is x squared a
times x is plus ax
and then when we multiply it by the
negative a
well it'll become negative a times x
minus a squared
so these middle two terms cancel out
and you are left with x squared minus a
squared you're left with a difference of
squares
x squared
minus a squared
so we have an interesting result right
over here
that x squared minus a squared is equal
to
is equal to
x plus a x plus a times x minus a
and so we can use and this is for any a
so we could use this pattern now
to factor this
here what is our a
our a is 3
this is x squared minus 3 squared or we
could say minus our a squared if we say
3 is a
and so to factor it this is just going
to be equal to
x plus
our a which is three times x minus our a
which is three so x plus three
times x minus three now let's do some
examples to really reinforce this idea
of factoring differences of squares
so let's say we want to factor
let me say
y squared
minus 25 it has to be a difference of
squares can't doesn't work with a sum of
squares
well in this case this is going to be y
and you have to confirm okay yeah 25 is
5 squared and y squared is well y
squared this is going to be y plus
something times y minus something and
what is that something well this right
here is 5 squared so it's y plus 5 times
y minus 5.
and the variable doesn't have to come
first we could write
121
minus
i'll introduce a new variable
minus
b squared well this is a difference of
squares because 121 is 11 squared so
this is going to be 11 plus something
times 11 minus something in this case
that something is going to be the thing
that was squared
so
11 plus b
times 11 minus b
so in general if you see a if you see a
difference of squares one square
being subtracted from another square and
it could be a numeric perfect square or
it could be a variable that has been
squared that can be that you could take
the square root of well then you could
say all right well that's just going to
be the first thing that's squared plus
the second thing that has that has been
squared times the first thing that was
squared minus the second thing that was
squared now some common mistakes that
i've seen people do including my son
when they first learn this is they say
okay it's easy to recognize the
difference of squares but then they say
oh is this y squared plus 25 times y
squared minus 25 no the important thing
to realize is
is that what is getting squared
over here
y is the thing getting squared and over
here it is 5 that is getting squared
those are the things that are getting
squared in this difference of squares
and so it's going to be y plus 5 times y
minus 5. i encourage you to just try
this out we have a whole practice
section on khan academy where you can do
many many more of these to become
familiar